ciao a tutti mi chiamo guglielmo e se vi
fate schifo questo video fa per voi con
l'arrivo dell'estate troppe persone
seguono i consigli sbagliati finiscono
per mettere a dieta l'unica cosa che non
dovrebbe mai perdere peso l'autostima
seguire la dieta sbagliata e sperare di
perdere peso e un pochino come essere
ciechi e seguire un cane senza occhi e
difficile di cattivo gusto anche da
questa volta è diverso ve lo prometto se
sicure te questi consigli quest'estate
proverete per la prima volta il brivido
di utilizzare il telo da mare come telo
da mare e non come il coperchio di una
bara partiamo dalla mattina per prima
cosa svegliatevi presto e fate colazione
con un pacco di cazzi vostri integrali
mi raccomando non confondetevi con i
cazzi degli altri perché al supermercato
rimettono sempre vicini ed è facile
confondersi potete inzuppare cazzi
vostri dove i par io personalmente
consiglio il latte di mandorla il latte
di mandorla è un alimento rarissime si
trova solamente nei supermercati d'elite
che vendono anche le scuse degli ex e le
scarpe che ti permettono di fare un
passo indietro a metà mattinata come
spuntino consiglio sempre della frutta
tropicale tipo mango morto che è
perfetto per tutte quelle persone che
dicono sempre di sì ho un [ __ ]
ideale per tutte le crocerossine era
fuori che ancora non hanno capito di
essere salite sull'ambulanza sbagliata
grazie per la sirena ragazzi ricordate
però che le persone non si cambiano al
massimo si sostituiscono come le
lavatrici non siete mica gesù è colui
trasformava l'acqua in vino colpisce al
massimo ci hanno avviato i murales di
persone perdano qui c'erano neanche le
piante per pranzo vi consiglio di
rimanere leggeri quindi magari del pesce
bianco che piano di fosforo e che vi
aiuta anche a ricordare ora per seguire
questa dieta importantissimo avere una
buona memoria ricordatevi perché avete
voluto bene delle persone che vi
trattavano come il cinese dei black eyed
peas
ricordatevi tutte le cose belle che mi
hanno detto prima di diventare piacevoli
comunas come questo motosega dal cup ma
soprattutto ricordatevi tutto quello che
c'è stato fra di voi e dimenticatelo se
volete proprio ricordarvi qualcosa e
ricordatevi le cose importanti piuttosto
se qualcuno magari vi ha attaccato per
il vostro peso preoccupatevi dello
spessore che può avere una persona di
questo tipo se magari siete stati
criticati per il vostro aspetto
immaginate quanto possa essere brutte
queste persone se poteste rivoltarla al
contrario con un calcione a vedere
quello che hanno dentro ora di belle
facce pieno instagram il problema è che
le hanno
le preziose non possono essere
photoshoppate se il vostro ragazzo di
critica la cellulite ecco preoccupati di
ebook in testa che certo mappe e se
magari il problema di alcuni vostri
amici è stato il vostro carattere
ricordate che non c'è niente di male a
non stare antipatico a qualcuno per
quello che si è molto peggio e sei
simpatici per quello che non si è
ricordatevelo sempre il vostro valore
non diminuisce solamente perchè
qualcun'altro incapace a riconoscerlo
ecco perché per contorno a pranzo
consiglio sempre un qualcosa di leggero
sarebbe ottimo nord julienne di amici
che siano capaci di farvi ridere e
andare allo stesso tempo in profondità
senza paura di chiedere scusa persone
capaci di gioire dei vostri successi e
di affrontarvi anche quando sarebbe
molto più facile darvi ragione anche
solo un pochino come gli unicorni della
foresta incantata troppo belli per
essere veri meteo istro affidatevi che
esistono là fuori alla fine
dell'arcobaleno anzi se volete sapere
dove trovate potete lasciare una
donazione al bue perché insieme al panda
gigante al canguro arboricolo sono
esseri a rischio di estinzione le
persone negative invece vi consiglio di
rilasciarle stare saranno anche loro a
rischio di estinzione ma non serve per
forza il vostro aiuto per proteggerle in
questo caso è giusto che la natura
faccia il suo corso dopo pranzo è
importantissimo allenare il buonumore
che a volte più difficile che fare sette
ore di crossfit di fila più difficile
contare anche tutti gli interventi
chirurgici a cui si è sottoposto il cane
umano facciamocene una ragione a volte
non è che ci si sveglia col piede storto
a volte il piede l'unica cosa che
riusciamo a mettere dritta durante la
giornata ma fidatevi di me la felicità è
come un mitra con l'unica differenza che
colpisce sempre le persone giuste le
persone felici scelgono di sorridere
sono i cretini quelli che si fanno
ridere alle spalle dagli altre finiamo
la giornata con la cena anche libera
mangiate quello che vi pare e mangiate
fino a sazietà ma non mangiate se posso
darvi un consiglio per riempire i vuoti
che vanno lasciato magari altre persone
il cibo non può tappare voragini così
grandi sono luoghi molto più profondi
non riuscirà a colmarli in piatto di
pasta con la cena temi nonna forse
quella se come dessert infine scegliete
l'amore di chi vi vuole bene che dolce
non a calori e scegliete l'affetto di
quelle persone che hanno il coraggio di
abbracciarmi ad agosto con 40 gradi
all'ombra persone che vi amano a priori
anche se indossate le crocs o i legging
color carne o se è andato in giro come
la sega perché se volete fare una dieta
equilibrata
l'unica cosa che dovete veramente
mettere sul piatto della bilancia sono i
gesti delle persone quello è l'unico
peso che conta perché se nel mare
possono notare le balene le orche
assassine allora ci potete notare pure
voi con qualche chilo in più usati
proselitismi ma ultimamente sto cercando
di mangiare solo le cose che mi fanno
star bene e smollare tutta la merda dove
merita di stare d'elba per è tipico
delle persone piccole attaccati qualcuno
perché è troppo grosso non dobbiamo
stupirci e io naturalmente vi mando un
bacio grande e vi invito a iscrivervi al
canale se non volete perdere i prossimi
video e vi invito a fare un piccolo
esperimento se volete lasciare un
commento
qua sotto non fatelo per me ma fatelo
per voi può sembrare una cosa tipo di
alcolisti anonimi o tipo di esercizio di
un terapista per un povero pazzo ma se
ti fa piacere scrivetevi qua sotto una
cosa carina o magari scrivetela per un
vostro amico e se non vi va di farlo
pubblicamente a velo su un foglio di
carta a casa oppure mandate un sms
privato non sono convinto che i
complimenti che imparate a fare a voi
stessi agli altri sono molto più
coraggiosi di qualsiasi critica
no no no grazie grazie ragazzi anche voi
seguirete questa dieta
scusate fanno dei lavori la parola sul
loro corpo ma stanno forgiando excalibur
cioè gli sprechi che cosa stanno facendo
armatura di iron man dai dopo a milano a
sant'ambrogio tiro di queste siri che
canta un telegrafo un messaggio in
codice ci stanno chiedendo aiuto